when you said in that video that
misleads would not be your first choice
you were referring to her physical looks
correct just the overall not I I look at
her I see her I hear what she says
whatever you wouldn't be a choice of
mine either to be honest with you I hope
you're not insulted I would not under
any circumstances have any interest in
you
I'm being I'm honest when I say it she I
would not have any interest in grotesque
stuff
grotesque stuff Trump wouldn't be
interested in misleads or Eugene Carroll
or the lawyer asking the question he's
just not interested the good news per
Trump is if he doesn't find you
attractive he wouldn't sexually assault
you
of course I would be much more inspired
if Trump were to say it doesn't matter
how attractive I find someone I would
never commit an act of sexual assault
that's not what he has chosen to say